the aim Sam is that the government wants
to send some signals to International
markets to calm the jitteriness we've
had there over the last week or so and
to essentially show the markets that the
government is not spending in a careless
carefreeway that they do still have an
eye on the money an eye on the borrowing
levels and one way of doing that they
say is by as Sir Robert Buckland said in
that interview
taking a rigorous approach to Bear Down
on public expenditure now we've had very
similar tone coming from quasi quattang
the chancellor writing in the newspapers
the telegraph this morning
um saying that he'll set out a plan to
get debt falling at the end of November
in his statement there and that they
would have sustainable and sensible
spending and borrowing and what might
that look like while Simon Clark another
key Ally of Liz trust the leveling up
secretary has done an interview in the
times today where he's talked about the
mismatches he sees it between having an
economy that is not productive enough
and having a large welfare Bill and how
those two are not compatible you also
talked about Capital spending projects
building stuff things that were
announced under the Boris Johnson
government and how that may need to be
prioritized or some of them
um delayed and I think you put all that
together and as you can see from the
times headline there many people take
this as potentially a return to the
austerity years of David Cameron
economists we were talking to yesterday
said that the combination of the level
of rising prices and inflation and all
of the tax cuts would mean that there
could potentially need to be spending
restraint in the order of what we got in
those first Cameron years now that I
think will alarm many conservative MPS
because it's certainly not what the
government stood on in 2019 in the
election it is alarming as well the
leaders and finance Ministers of the
devolved governments in Wales Scotland
and Northern Ireland who of course get
an apportion appropriate amount of money
from the UK government centrally and are
potentially seeing that those amounts
down they have written to quasi-karting
today in which they've been expressing
their alarm about the situation they've
said that the UK government has chosen
to make things significantly worse by
announcing a huge package of tax cuts
for the most wealthy without any
credible explanation of how these will
be paid for
Urgent action is required now to address
the issues facing our economy public
services and households across the
country such action cannot wait until
the update you have announced will take
place in November so clearly devolved
leaders not reassured I think as
conservative MPS make their way to
Birmingham this weekend for the annual
get-together the annual conference many
are looking for reassurance as well
today Mark Fullbrook who is the chief of
staff and Liz truss has sent a message
out to all MPS saying he will be
regularly sending them Graphics to their
mobile phone number to help explain the
plan saying that it's clear that where
people understand it they are prepared
to give it a chance so a lot of
reassuring and reassurance going on both
to International markets but also to the
party Zone MPS